i'm regretting promising alina that i'm
gonna delete my social media because now
she's constantly on my back about it and
i feel that her asking me to delete it
is coming from a place of insecurity
rather than a place of
wanting our relationship to be in a
better place
you're distracting me by saying
something like oh i love you
i want to be with you i know that i did
wrong i do love you you still
communicate with other girls
this is how you show your love
i love you
is anybody texted you
uh just like
a girl
did you get any messages from someone
from russia
her name is
masha
uh
i want to tell you something
i put you on a test
with my friend and i asked her to flirt
with you
just to make sure that you
not going to
cheat on me
you tried setting me up
yes
so you
don't trust me and you had you tried to
get one of your friends
clear with you so girl you sent her
yes and you didn't tell me about
her which means you
lied again we didn't really even talk it
was like two messages i know what you
were talking about
i know everything
it's offensive that you don't trust me
enough to you would try to set me up and
set me up for failure you still think
it's normal that you can communicate
with
just random girls
she messaged me
you said that whole thing and you text
her back i basically said that
well it'd be cool if you came and
visited us so i asked her if she had a
swimsuit but like i'm just a i'm
i didn't
it's just
a kind
gesture i don't take it seriously
you are going to delete your social
media accounts right now
you want to do it right now yes right
now
oh we can delete it right now but
i have photos i want to save on there
first before i delete it
it's going to take a long time to
download all those photos i feel like so
what
so
like this is my graduation picture i
don't have that anywhere else really so
save it now quickly we have to use this
park wi-fi it's way too hot
we can do it when we get home all right
so as soon as we get home
when we get home we'll go home we'll
save those pictures and then i'll delete
it
[Music]
you